I'm so pleased to open this play space  for great waving children this is part  of a 1 million pound investment that  we're making into the most boats across  the district I'd like to thank all  counselors that have been persevered in  this process also officers from Rockford  district council making this possible I  hope many more in the very near future  by waking parish council are delighted  that refurbishment to play space and  outdoor gym equipment our children and  adults to benefit the wider  opportunities to socialize play and be  active the parish I'd like to thank all  who brought the scheme to fruition and  the grant funding that  [Music]